i really don't want to be pregnant or
have a kid within the next one or two
years i like really kind of want to
enjoy
this stage right now but then
then i'm looking at 37 yeah and i'm like
okay getting up there and so when you're
47 you're like i still don't really want
to be pregnant the next year or two yeah
but then i was saying that like i'd be
down to be a surrogate and i said i
don't think so there's no way you'd give
the baby it was even like what like
that's a hot take expectations for women
are really interesting because it's like
if you have a kid too young you're a
[ __ ] if you don't have kids ever you're
useless if you work too hard you're not
a good mother if you're only a mother
then you're not you're just a major yeah
yeah if you work out a lot then you look
like a man if you don't work out at all
then you're gross like
dude shut the [ __ ] up
[Music]
hello welcome back to big mood i'm nikki
limo and we are all together in the
physical realm right now who else is
here just for those people not watching
the video hi it's gina i'm here in vegas
yay and this is tiff
and oh my god i didn't actually quit
yeah we she quit and we were like please
just come back to ten year part of the
show yeah i am gonna quit just not today
yeah yeah you're the star like we have
to we had to raise give her a raise i've
been very busy with my real job sorry
um
yeah so we're all borrowing the [ __ ]
they don't tell you set right now it is
now a big mood set if you can see from
our signs yeah very official
professional please we spent a lot of
money
this graphic designer was involved and
everything um but everybody's here at my
house yeah i'm so excited to have
everybody your houses this is nice
it is huge it's so nice i'm in love with
how much light you get
that was definitely the selling point
for me too and it's not direct sunlight
it's like yeah just flooded with like
indirect natural plant growing like you
know how you always say every time you
sage you're like love and light lives
here yeah it literally does yeah yeah we
manifested a girl i walked into a room
earlier and i was like hey nikki can i
whoa
this is huge your closet is ginormous i
love it here and i love my new bedroom
thank you you're welcome yeah live's
here now
and she's gonna commute every day people
are gonna take that seriously and be
like oh [ __ ] it's only a 45 minute
probably the same amount as traffic that
is true that is true the same amount of
guests yeah exactly yeah so what are you
guys doing um we're the fidget couch and
we have a baby they're doing their nails
i'm actually doing pouches over here
listen okay so before we started this we
were like hey we usually do a ketchup
episode but we did just do a catch-up
episode a few weeks ago on a zoom and
also we started having like some really
good conversations while we were getting
ready and i'm like this should be
something we talk about because like
literally the show started from what our
group texts would be about if like and
then we just added you guys into it like
hey we're the girl the girlfriend group
that you could be part of and also we
structured it a little bit more right
like having specific topics then we
started structuring it more exactly but
then we were having really good
conversation because we were genuinely
catching up we haven't seen jess in like
three four months oh my gosh january
so yeah almost half a year and um
nobody's we haven't seen tiff since she
gave birth well i haven't i was pregnant
gina has but yeah i haven't seen tiff
since she was pregnant um so we just
started catching up on a bunch of stuff
and it was while we were getting ready
and i feel like the best conversations
come out like while we're yeah and then
we're just gonna continue to get ready
yeah
and we're like let's just talk about
this on the show like whatever comes up
like what we would naturally
ask each other or start talking about
like just we'll just start talking about
that yeah so jess you already mentioned
that you have a real job now yes so
you've talked about that a few times on
the show yeah and also i don't really
want to talk too much about my job yeah
um i have to kind of keep it low-key
but
yeah
but what about your personal life
my personal life there is none
i don't have anything to catch up on but
i think we should just talk about one
thing that we were okay middle of the
conversation that we were having when we
were like we should talk about this was
that um
tiff gave birth and i was she was asking
if any of my new neighbor friends had
kids and i was like well actually our
next door neighbors that we hang out
with all the time are expecting in
august and i said that they're like a
few years older than us they're in their
early 40s and she was like whoa or they
they were able to get pregnant i was
like well
they actually have a surrogate and
lucky yeah it was after quite a few
times and then like maybe we just need
someone else's body to do it and so it's
their egg and their sperm but then they
have a surrogate and so tiff was asking
the details on that like are they local
and i was like yeah actually i think
they said that it was their friend who
they like kind of they were
acquaintances they were friends but they
didn't know that she did this and then
um she's been doing it for like 10 years
because they knew her all along and she
just had was pregnant and didn't have
kids
yeah i don't think they saw her that
often and so i was like yeah it wasn't
that weird um but yeah so they felt
really comfortable with her and and so
they're expecting in august when i met
them they were drinking and they're like
we're expecting in august i was like no
judgment um i don't it's 2022 i don't
know what the new rules are
like no it's a surrogate that's awesome
yeah yeah but then i was saying that
like i'd be down to be a surrogate and
then i said i don't think so there's no
way you'd give the baby it was even like
what like that's a hot take well i mean
i've actually said this for years like
years ago i've said this before um
and like i'm like i'd be down to be a
surrogate the only part that i'm like
i really have to do a lot of self-work
like a lot of mental preparation is the
letting go of the baby part because i
can totally do the pregnancy i enjoy
being pregnant i enjoy i mean i haven't
had a like the best most positive
birth experience yet but like i'm eager
to have that like
birth experience and like have that's
what you were practicing for yeah like
that's what i've been preparing for and
like having traumatic births like two
traumatic births i'm i'm like excited
and eager to have a birth that heals
that trauma that's so interesting
because it's like the reverse effect if
i had two traumatic births i'd be like
i'm never [ __ ] doing this
it's because i know what it can be and
it's like so
disappointing and upsetting
yeah and then like it's also like i know
every woman can get that like that's our
birthright like as women like we're made
to have kids we were made to bring
humans into this world and so
we weren't created in a way where it was
supposed to be traumatic like that's not
how we were made so that's how like i
know it's like i'm [ __ ] entitled to a
bomb-ass birth i'm gonna get it like
it's gonna happen she's gonna keep
popping out baby here's the best thing
when i'm ready you can be my surgeon
yeah that's what i was thinking i'll be
too lazy to take care of the kid i'll
just dump it off no no you can't take
care of your own
actually i'll keep your kid for the
first like two months yeah because
that's my favorite the newborn stage is
like yeah would it be weirder if you
you know did all that and gave the kid
away never saw it again or if you kept
up with its life and like would you be
more attached do you think more like an
adoption i don't know that's why i'm
such an interesting topic that's why i'm
saying like i would really need to like
i wouldn't put myself through that until
like i'm for sure like okay i'm here
like just like how i was prepared and
ready for like birth i'm like let's do
this like i have to get myself i have to
do the work the self work to actually be
mentally prepared to go through
something like this but if you're asking
me that question like would it be
easier to not ever know this kid again
or to have this kid in my life yeah i
personally would prefer to have this kid
in my life and like keep up with them
and especially if it's like a friend
yeah that's what i was thinking yeah
that's like kind of like a
sort of like a family member and a
weirdo
and like i would want to know like how
they are how they're doing i mean even
my friends kids like i love them so much
as if like they are my family like you
know like you definitely are like a
mom the mom of the group like you like
that i like stuff like nurturing kids
and all that stuff yeah like seeing them
grow up and like i don't know just being
a part of their lives and
so if i were to give if i were to be a
surrogate to a complete stranger i think
that would be even harder for me mm-hmm
that's why i said there you go
interesting
same yeah well you got to find a sperm
first that's true
um
so then i was also saying well you want
to have another kid yeah like you were
even talking about how
right after giving birth you're like i
can't wait for the next one all right
yeah yeah yeah girl no both me and casey
like we see luca and we're like oh my
god we can't wait to have more kids i
was like maybe we can have two more like
maybe i don't know can you afford that
we're like
my other
parent friends that just became new
parents are like this is way too much
work but you're the first one i've heard
that's like i want another one right now
yeah that's insane um yeah do you think
that if you went through
that birthing process on your second or
your second one with casey yeah um that
and it was not traumatic that that would
heal it and then you wouldn't really
care about the question doing a
surrogate thing yeah i don't know
because right now i'm more eager about
like it's like
it's kind of like you know when people
are so driven to meet certain goal posts
in their lives yes and like for in their
career for example and then once they
hit like the whole time they're like i'm
gonna hit that goal post like i'm gonna
get that
like do people get motivated and they
move the goal post to the next
absolutely yeah so i don't know if like
oh i'm gonna be like one i need to have
a second amazing okay let me give you a
hot take and i know people don't like it
when you compare children to dogs
when i got my first dog right maddie it
was amazing i loved her we had a great
bond
and i instantly wanted another one as
soon as i got sophie it became way too
much [ __ ] [ __ ] to handle maddie was
[ __ ] pissed at me
like her whole personality changed
because she was no longer the [ __ ]
queen of the house
and like everything was twice as
expensive everything was twice as
[ __ ] like so i'm just thinking like
do you think that's really gonna
translate into double love and double
happiness or do you think it's gonna
divide
everything in half and be more stressful
yeah well i can tell you that already
since i have isaac in my life like it
has doubled well also but two at the
same time no i know that's the part that
i've never seen yeah because that's what
i'm saying at the same time you know
what i've heard is that two kids like
around the same age i heard that's like
the hardest like going from one to two
is the hardest and then after that like
you had three four or five like it's
like the same after and i know people
don't like to compare kids to cats
i didn't want a second cat i had my cat
frankly that was no you have to wait too
many and then my ex wanted to adopt this
second kitten and i was like frank
franklin will never go for it and
franklin like fell in love with him and
so then we ended up with joe with joe
and then my ex broke up and we couldn't
separate them so i had to take both of
them in my like tiny little place and it
was so expensive i couldn't even afford
to feed myself and like i was just hard
like having two cats double the kitty
litter double like everything and um and
they don't even like need to go on walks
or anything
but then we had a litter of kittens yeah
yeah you had anything there's 14 cats in
your house it was like you know what how
many were there there were seven toys
yeah
excuse
[Applause]
we can do this forever
so you know maybe it's like that yeah
you know you get two it's hard you get
seven you're fine
you know right
well
they entertain each other difficulty
graph like peaks and it just drops
immediately
i'm pretty happy with just like if i had
a circuit and we just had twins right
off the bat
yes you know what awesome cool you know
it's more possible like as you get older
if you're doing ivf especially like yeah
yeah
my great aunt had triplets at like 40.
yeah that's a lot wild yeah doesn't know
for me but
no but we were seriously considering a
surrogate because
i that was like
the part that i'm like one i don't know
we've never like really seriously
like tried to get pregnant like gave it
a go we were like kind of like whatever
happens happens we're not we're not
being careful so you never once were
ovulating and was like i'm gonna make
him nut in me tonight no i mean i was
tracking my ovulation cycles and i was
like if we do it this week this is my
ovulation week and we'll have sex like
one time maybe two times that week and
nothing but nothing like
that's how we were for years yeah i
remember you saying that and then when
you seriously were like right you were
like every day i do it every day yeah
we've never friends have sex y'all
yeah with sex
[Laughter]
yeah well not we were just talking about
different options because after talking
to those neighbors we were like that i
didn't even realize i've been feeling a
pressure at 35 that like oh [ __ ] i have
this tiny window you know i really kind
of feel like you have to get it in
before 40. i used to think you have to
get in before 35 but yeah we took that
um fertility test and they were like
your eggs are really healthy but you
have a smaller window like basically i'm
gonna start menopause
sooner than the rest of my peers because
i have very short cycles um that's like
21 days
and so you're just like way more eggs
yeah
you're like machine guns yeah they're
just like falling out of me i can't get
all my eggs coming out and so um i was
like i'm feeling an immense amount of
pressure because we just moved here i
really like our life right now every
time we
do a new thing or like progress a little
bit more i'm like i get more selfish
it's like that gwen stefani song
where i'm like i always felt like i'd be
a mom but the older i get the more
selfish i am um can you just freeze them
and well i thought about that but super
invasive too enough i'm going to be that
invasive i might as well do a surrogate
thing
it is yeah you check yourself and then
like do you just pop right there harvest
your eggs
and they freeze it and you just pay for
them just one time for them now i'm
scared
um but maybe i don't know maybe i it's
an option
i'm considering everything but the one
thing i don't want is i really don't
want to be pregnant or have a kid within
the next one or two years i like really
kind of want to enjoy
this stage right now but then
then i'm looking at 37 yeah and i'm like
okay getting up there and so when you're
47 you're like i still don't really want
to be pregnant next year or two
so then our neighbors are 41 and 42 and
they're just now having their kids look
they look really young they're very
active they they're not like
tired and old and stuff and like so i
don't feel like steve and i will be like
tired i think 40 active yeah because 40
is not even old i know but you know like
how 40 year olds that work nine to fives
like every day like you kind of get like
a very
like run down like you're being an adult
too long and i feel like adults that are
have more kid-like jobs or like get to
explore their child's side more like you
know gina gets to go play video games
all the time like we get to be on
youtube he's basically 12. um our
friends that are that are you doing the
surrogate they're real estate agents so
they're like it's still like not a
a grinding office nine to five so you're
saying i'm gonna auditing a job
so you're saying it's downhill from here
and we're also all not white so yeah
we're like not asian
like those white people those office
jobs
oh man
their eggs are just
no i
i just think that like
the 40 year olds that have had kids that
i've known that are that complain about
it that are like oh you should have kids
do it while you're younger or younger
they all
are tired yeah and they work full-time
jobs and they don't really have
they don't really get their child's side
to play very often and i feel like
they're just missing
you know that that child said and so
like when it comes to like the joy you
get through your kid of like
experiencing childhood wonderment again
it's like not as they're too detached
they're too detached exactly they don't
get to
get into it as easily and i feel like
steve and i would like i feel like we're
very like kids like whenever my nephew's
over or my nieces and nephews we play
hide and seek we go like we play pool we
want to do all the [ __ ] fun stuff
and if anything i'd have to be too a
little more careful because like if they
want ice cream for breakfast like i'm
[ __ ] like yeah that sounds dope like
let's do that
um you're the favorite hunt yeah the
favorites yeah yeah you'd probably just
be a really good auntie to be honest
what if we just had all this money
because we don't have kids and we just
[ __ ] spoil the [ __ ] out of them we're
just like the fairy god parents to like
everyone yeah what do you want you want
a [ __ ] water slide i got you your
parents can't fight your parents can't
afford it but i can't pay their taxes
and stuff gentlemen father's day is just
around the corner and our friends at
manscaped are here to ensure that the
dad in your life is looking like a daddy
snack you know what i'm saying you can
find their signature lawnmower 4.0 in
the manscape performance package 4.0 for
the perfect bundle to tackle any and all
quote unquote old man hair from head to
toe this is no dad joke you can treat
him and yourself to join the 4 million
men worldwide who trust manscape with
this exclusive offer you get 20 off plus
free shipping with the code mood at
manscape.com trust me his dad bod will
thank you i personally gifted it to my
husband who is not a dad yet but he does
have
somewhat of a dad bod a very sexy dad
bod i might add and this just cleans up
all of the all of the stuff that is you
know surrounding the area that we might
like to uh play with you know what i'm
saying and if he's been using the same
trimmer for his body and face please do
him a favor and throw that out the
window right now and give him the
upgrade he deserves manscape also just
launched their brand new boxers 2.0
there are so many products that are
great at manscape right now these new
boxers are packed with revolutionary
features including the jewel pouch
designed to cradle his boys in their own
special space and this right here is a
game changer so get 20 off plus free
shipping with code mood at manscape.com
that's 20 off plus free shipping with
code mood at manscape.com
let's look at all of that package in its
wondrous glory
all right now it's time to talk about my
favorite vitamins ritual i am such a
huge fan i've been taking ritual for
many years i took ritual throughout my
entire pregnancy and now that i'm
breastfeeding i've been taking their
post-natal vitamins as well as the
essential protein which just gives my
body all the nutrients it needs with my
more nutrient demanding body since i'm
breastfeeding you know what we deserve
to know what we're putting in our bodies
and why especially when it comes to
something that we take every day like
vitamins gaps in diet shouldn't be
ignored over 97 of women aged 19 through
50 are not getting enough vitamin d from
their diet and 95 percent are not
getting their recommended daily intake
of key omega-3s rituals essential for
women 18 and over multivitamin was
formulated by exhaustive research to
help fill nutrient gaps in the diets of
women ages 18 and up it is formulated
with nutrients to help support brain
health bone health blood health and
provide antioxidant support but rachel
didn't stop there they invested in a
gold standard university-led clinical
trial to prove the impact of essential
for women 18 and over multivitamin the
results it was shown to increase vitamin
d levels by 43 and omega-3 dha levels by
41 in 12 weeks the clinical study was
published in leading scientific journal
frontiers and nutrition ritual is
committed to third-party testing from
usp and non-gmo project traceable and
vegan-friendly ingredients and always
clear communication
no shady stuff ritual is offering our
listeners 10 off during your first three
months visit ritual.com
big mood and turn healthy habits into a
ritual that's 10 off ritual.com
big mood that's what i feel like when it
comes to having kids like one i kind of
want kids because i need like i need
like i want to see
what my kid would be like you know like
i want to see what i would make yeah and
then also like when i grow up that's
what makes me not want to do it the most
and when i grow old it's like it'd be
nice to have like our own little family
that comes to visit
yeah but also at the same time like or i
just don't have kids make all the money
blow all my money before i die and not
to worry about passing it on to anything
else but then what about the like when
you're old part like exactly that's
that's really the part people ignore you
anyway i don't think that like i don't
think kids should be obligated to take
care of their parents but yeah it's more
of like the loneliness aspect of people
are still old people are still lonely
i'm gonna tell you right now there's
people in nursing homes there's people
in like nice facilities there's people
in beautiful neighborhoods expensive
rich ones they get [ __ ] ignored like
having kids doesn't mean they're gonna
come around and i mean so many people's
grandparents but i guess knowing i put
the life out into the world as like an
old person and it's not like well are we
end now like our bloodline ends now it
really isn't though like your brother
had kids or whatever right like yeah
oh no i'm an only child of my parents
your gene pool doesn't need to continue
jesus christ
that's true eugene and gina poole
needs to enjoy i'm an only child from
both of my parents too yeah so if i were
to not have a kid it ends like this
million year like three million year
lineage like this [ __ ] like my
ancestors like we worked so hard for so
long
oh my god
no i just i i personally don't agree
with the sentiments of like oh i'm gonna
be alone if i don't have kids do you
think it's a cultural thing though
because
i feel like at least in my culture in
mexican culture like older people are
taken care of by their families like
they they we don't stuff our
grandma grandma and grandpa into a home
and like they're constantly living so
when your mom gets old enough so she
can't take care of herself she's going
to live in your house yeah either mine
or maybe it wouldn't be me i don't i
don't think so yeah
i wouldn't want to like encroach on my
kids like that i guess but
um for me it's not necessarily like the
like who's gonna visit me in my nursing
home it's more like uh i was raised in a
big family steve was raised in a big
family we have big christmases big
thanksgivings and everyone has their
little pods of families that come
together and it's like we would be the
one the pod without a pod like would you
be the couple like it just i've never we
don't have that in my family like
there's not just like so you wouldn't
fit in a little pod it's not even about
fitting in it's just like i want the joy
of having our little pod that meets up
with the bigger pod
i like that that's exciting for me like
that like going to christmas and like
meeting the rest of the family and they
play with the cousins and like that
that's the childhood i grew up in and i
i guess you kind of want your childhood
replicated in some way if you came from
like that environment
um but
i don't want to physically do it yeah
yeah i mean like
you would be changing your entire life
yeah for like this kind of fantasy of a
pretty christmas and i'm just like okay
so let me put this passage you guys okay
we have another couple that we're best
friends with in vegas like chad and v
and they're a little bit older than us
too yeah and they've always been they're
very logical very spreadsheet oriented
very uh left-brained people and they've
always been no kids like since they met
they've been together for 15 years no
kids they both agreed on it they broke
down like the financial aspects of it
all the stuff yeah but now they have a
huge hit show on youtube they have toys
in target they're they just they're
opening like a chuck e cheese like kids
jungle gym type of place they make tons
like they have many i don't want to like
get into their finances like they make a
lot of money now way more money than
when they did those spreadsheets and as
v is getting older she's like
i kind of want a kid now because it's
like they have all this stuff and they
have this video game room they have like
an arcade they're like little they look
fun they're like their lives are kind of
they have a round of applause
they have a kids show yeah we have a
delorean yeah cool signed by all the
back to the future author i mean the
actors and gosh yeah they're like huge
nerds they're into like power rangers
ninja turtles they like all that kid
[ __ ] they have nieces and nephews um and
then yeah she never thought that she
wanted her own kids and then
she's like you know we where is this all
gonna go is it are we gonna will it to
our nieces and nephews is it just that
yeah
that's the end of the legacy
i think they're kind of feeling like
they have this huge house like it's like
a six thousand square foot house and
like it's just them so they just don't
have like a what's next that they wanted
yeah
yeah they're just going to retire and
then now they're they need something
else 40 and they're retired and where
does it go adopt
yeah yeah but you know having kids in
general i think it's more of a you know
lifetime having someone else yeah
yeah
i could see that really interesting i
could see like if i've reached every
other possible goal and there's nothing
else like where it wouldn't really
change your life
yeah want to pivot like if i could have
a ton of nannies that where i could
still like i'm not i think it's just the
stress of like
raising a child yourself from like that
that's a struggle and like i'm just not
willing to balancing your work life and
like a child as well because like it
used to be back in the day if you're a
mom you just get to be a mom yeah but
now you like literally you can't survive
off one income so you have to do all of
the things and it's super stressful and
then where do you blame the kids because
that's the stress point the kids kids
traumatized and then it's like they get
ignored because you have to work still
yeah if you could just like
be a mom because you find joy in being a
mom that would be great and i think that
i would like that if i just focused on
that but right now there's so many other
things i want to do that i don't think i
could just focus on that same i just
every time i'm around a kid i never
think oh i want to hang out with you
more
i'm just like
depending it's fine if you don't if you
don't because then
because i know you've talked about this
a lot just where you're like i just
don't have that maternal instinct yeah i
don't feel a connection i don't feel
that want and i think that's perfectly
fine because everyone has different
preferences or different like
goals or aspirations yeah whatever it is
things that feed you yeah exactly and
that just doesn't and it's okay yeah it
doesn't have to and i think it's the
societal pressure that makes you feel
like something's wrong with you yeah
absolutely that actually that thought
came up when you were talking about
being a surrogate and then jess was just
like why would you ever i was like why
would you why would you put your body
through that and then you don't even
keep it
like who even signs up to be a surrogate
like you're [ __ ] crazy
and then get rid of it people that
there's a greater good to it like
helping others thank god there's people
that want that and then there's people
that want that because if there were
only no one would be no population
so yeah thank god we have gays thank god
we have like valentine's day
yeah
i don't know
yeah i think it's fine because then like
i know i've i've also looked into um
like i've come across like articles
about
women or even men that are or i guess
it's not that crazy for men because
that's more normal but women saying like
i just don't want to have kids ever and
they're really young and they struggle
to to try to get um
like sterilized i guess is the term or
yeah like the doctors won't let you like
yeah yeah even my cousin so i just saw
my cousin she has four kids um and she
stopped having kids when she was like 23
or 24 like she was really young when she
had her kids
and she was looking into getting a
hysterectomy but like just the uterus
not like the ovaries or anything yeah
and she couldn't find a doctor no one's
going to do it but she's going to be
like 26 yeah
i think you're gonna change your mind
yeah they won't do her exactly she
already had four kids and she was like
no i don't care i don't want my uterus
like i don't want to be bleeding if i
don't want to have any there's another
thing you can get done which is like an
ablation where they just like burn the
inside of your
your um so like an egg can't implant
into it or still
you don't have no there's no more
appearance
yeah but like also you're not getting
rid of your ovaries and like screwing
with your hormones and all that stuff no
she still has her ovaries but okay yeah
so i asked her too i'm like well what
about your hormones and stuff and she's
like no i still have my ovaries yeah i
have to take hormones i'm perfectly fine
she's already done she's i think it's
like 15 years you know 14 years that she
hasn't had her uterus and like she's
pregnant and she's yeah she's done not
on hormone replacement because her body
still yeah yeah so yeah but yeah the
fact how did she get someone to do it
she so she lives in new mexico and she
did so much research she went to so many
doctors and no one would do it she
finally found a doctor that was like
yeah i'll do it like why not if you've
already had four kids yeah exactly like
that's how [ __ ] she gonna have more
that's how ridiculous the the the the
society and the system and it's so like
sexist and like actually right now with
the whole talk about like roe versus
wade yeah being revoked or whatever the
term is like overturned that one yeah
overturn
i'm like why
do people have opportunities
exactly why it's not up to anyone i
think it's a different woman it's
honestly i think it's like a power play
it's like some [ __ ] i don't think
they really feel that way because like
they're all rich and their wives and
cousins and nieces and nephews can you
know still
get stuff done if they need it done
exactly i don't know it's
it's very triggering where it's like i
like
me i am pro-choice and i'm like why is
why do they need to be laws to tell
women that they can't do something with
their body like i've already been like
so traumatized with people especially
like
giving birth to luca and like doctors
like telling me like you need to do this
you need to do that and like i'm not
even going to ask for consent i'm
shoving my fingers up your vagina it's
just like
i have i feel so powerless with my own
body
in a situation like that that i can't
like even imagine
having like an experience where
i am not in a position or like i
wouldn't want to bring life into this
world or whatever it is and then being
told like well you can't you're going to
have to put up with it and it's just
i don't know it's particularly
triggering expectations for women are
really interesting because it's like if
you have a kid too young you're a [ __ ]
if you don't have kids ever you're
useless if you work too hard you're not
a good mother if you're only a mother
then you're not you're just a major yeah
yeah if you work out a lot then you look
like a man if you don't work out at all
then you're gross like
dude shut the [ __ ] up man yeah [ __ ] off
just live your [ __ ] life
yeah i really find it hard to understand
why people
give a [ __ ] about about like what other
people do like with their personal
choices but then there's certain times
where i'm like okay i get where it makes
sense for me on a superficial level like
you have an hoa in your neighborhood
right yeah your neighborhood is worth a
lot more because people are kept in line
so i'm like trying to make myself
understand why people want
to put
pressures and behavioral restrictions on
other people and i'm like okay can i
understand for any [ __ ] reason
why you have any say in my life or my
choices or what i'm doing and i think
that they've honestly truly just believe
but it's that they're doing the best
thing for
the culture or whatever i don't know i
can't i mean i don't necessarily agree
with it but i'm just like how
do they justify feeling like they have a
right to tell me what to do i think oh
from what i know about like pro-life
argument is like how are you going to
murder a human
and because they truly believe that it's
yeah i've always asked that that's the
question i'd like to ask people it's
like if you think
if you think life starts at conception
when an egg is fertilized
then if
if you were in a uh what is it what is
it those buildings the ivf buildings yes
exactly right and it was on fire would
you save the case full of 20
fertilizer eggs that are now you know
lives or would you save that
five-year-old girl that needs you to
carry her out
yeah and you definitely say there's a
lot of embryos that get discarded like
in the ivf yeah they probably don't even
agree with ivf at all then right right i
mean i don't know
but but also
for people that want to have more kids
they're like it's for procreation so
they they're okay with ivf but then it's
like but the whole concept the whole
process of it
it's conflicting
did you do you save that one
five-year-old girl or do you save the 20
cases of lives if they're all alive yeah
for the greater goods or are you gonna
you know let 20 people die i think the
part that i take the biggest issue with
like the pro-life stance is the fact
that they don't look into what happens
to that child that is now being forced
to come into this world to exist like
to a mother that probably is gonna be
resentful towards the child because she
was forced to have this kid or to like a
very um unfortunate situation where like
the child can't be brought up by
his mother his or her mother that to the
point where now they have to go into a
foster care system or maybe get adopted
that's a nice story but even still like
who knows like where this life is gonna
lead and those are the same people that
vote against that's the part welfare
that's the part
there's gonna be no support for this
person now that they are being forced to
come into this existence like i don't
understand so i think that's why like
there's also another argument
that is like taking it a step back so
it's like now you have to be more
careful with sex and like what like how
people view sex and how they just view
it really like loosely to the point
where it's like let's just be
let's not be careful
and people really think there's just
people having sex and getting abortions
every other week i mean there's if
someone's doing that there may be some
mentally ill woman doing that in the
world i'm not saying she doesn't exist
but that's not what
you're doing and there's also people
like my friend she's on birth control
she's always been on birth control for
some reason like she gets pregnant even
with birth control and there's just so
much it's just not she's the point zero
one and she's like i have to go so on
time like i take it at the same time
every time and she's like she's who's
that sperm i know right this man
and it's like well what about her like
she's being careful she's having
protected sex and
but getting pregnant even at that point
they're like the that's actually what
they call them well they shouldn't have
sex at all exactly yeah you shouldn't
have sex at all it's your fault for
yourself unless you're ready to raise a
child today yeah which is literally just
not like
idea it's not like realistic you know
it's ideal but it's not realistic and
teaching people like what do we learn
about teaching kids celibacy the other
thing is right it actually makes it work
i think there's a confusion too because
i've met and converted some pro-life
people who i didn't think that was
possible i know but i think if you try
to understand their side like you were
just like there's many different reasons
people would be pro-life and i think
there's a spectrum of beliefs going on
and there are a lot of pro-li or there
are some that i've met that um think
that pro-life or pro-choice means
pro-abortion like you're just you want
people yeah abortions yeah and i get one
every saturday really what it is because
for me personally i made the decision
long ago that if i was gonna have sex
and i accidentally got pregnant even
with my birth control hearing all these
stories yeah i was like i will have the
child and i will
be a responsible mother is to the best
of my abilities i will not get an
abortion yeah same i don't make a choice
absolutely never put myself through that
but i i have exactly a choice to do that
like i
some people i know
wouldn't be able to support a child they
could just don't have the means to are
they supposed to never have sex the rest
of their life it's like it's not up to
me like i personally would never get an
abortion but i'm not gonna stop tell
someone else exactly like that's not
fair and so a lot
not a lot i shouldn't say a lot it's
been like two people that
like came over to the other side like oh
i thought just anyone that was
pro-choice means like if you got
pregnant you wanted to abortion like i'm
like that's no that's not how that's not
how it works i i personally couldn't do
it but
i know that about myself going into it
and there's some people that get put in
so many different situations there's an
unimaginable
unimaginable about amount of situations
a person could get pregnant against
their will yeah and people are like well
you know race we're rape and incest
there's only like a small portion of
them people always use that argument but
i'm like there's
okay i i had an abusive
ex-partner who i woke up to them having
sex with me yeah unprotected like i what
about that like that was my boyfriend we
have had sex before i didn't consent to
that right i mean technically that's
rape but like how many
drunk
times are people together in college or
something yeah yeah and it's like it's
not her whole life now because she
didn't consent to it yeah and then like
the guy that
impregnated her there's not a whole lot
that is really tying him to this
like yeah i guess you could go after him
and it's
it's a whole like long process with
courts and all this stuff and in the
meantime this woman has to like go
through
giving birth and like pregnancy raising
his child be up to
the person giving like that the life is
supported on mm-hmm right yeah i just
don't want kids because i still like
sleeping in so much i don't know what
yeah i'm like how would you even
possibly take care of a child right like
even if you wanted to exactly i love
sleeping in two but i got used to it
like i love my kid more i'm still way
too selfish right now and i don't even
know how it would work
like
especially with my job now if i were to
be pregnant can you imagine like
streaming and you just got a baby on
your lap oh god
oh god it's like my nightmare that is my
nightmare so like there are times i'm
like man kids are cute maybe i want one
and then i see a screaming little
banshee in target and i'm like
you know what though it's crazy because
casey and i were having this
conversation before when luka was crying
like
him crying is so [ __ ] cute that it
doesn't even bother us yeah like when
it's your kids yeah and i think and i
was telling you i'm like it's definitely
an evolutionary like thing because if we
couldn't stand lucas cries like we
wouldn't be able to like survive as a
human race yeah yeah exactly
yeah so your own kid
i don't i don't think you
find it like unbearable like other
people's kids maybe yeah yeah i've never
changed the diaper in my life whoa
really yeah 35 wow never change the
diaper don't recommend it today's the
day yeah
i don't i don't recommend it
i mean i don't want to um but i'm also
like
am i even i don't even know the basics
of like
especially with the board especially
with a boy you got to like wipe around
all this stuff actually [ __ ] boy i feel
like it's easier yeah
it's more difficult because there's like
like flaps
and then and then maybe i'm just
uncomfortable touching a boy no and then
you have to go from front to back and
like with the boy it's just like you
just just go up and then just clean her
up
just [ __ ] take the wife and just go
nuts in the dishwasher
i just dunk them in
yeah just
i guess yeah because it won't there's
there's less of a risk of it going
inside the majority i'm just like yeah i
don't know there's just little baby nuts
and it's still
yeah
definitely rather weird
i've never changed a girl diaper me
neither those are peony hats yeah
i've changed a lot of people yeah
because you've only had boys that's so
funny
and oh yeah oh yeah even though we're
here with tiff
we haven't even met the baby yet yeah
they haven't met luca yet
because uh baby is currently with casey
it's a scam it's a scam yeah
and then he doesn't really exist earlier
i came into the room never actually seen
him oh that was good
do you tell him tell them earlier i came
into the room but like i didn't want to
look because i didn't know if the baby
was here yet she was in her face the
case was different guess what's hidden
here and i was in my pj's because the
baby here they're like no i'm like okay
good i wanted to make a good first
impression
i didn't have my clothes like he's gonna
remember you i don't even know i didn't
have my makeup we'll document it
we're going to see if you could come
later and you guys can finally meet him
i'm so excited for you guys to meet him
because me too because he's just so like
i know i'm biased because i'm his mother
but he's so [ __ ] beautiful yeah
anything you say i don't believe it
until i see it i'll make my own decision
actually can you be objectively on it i
know you will be able to say no this
baby sucks take it back
no tell me because that's beautiful
see my kids without my mom eyes yeah i
wish i could see them like how a
stranger sees them like are they really
cute because people tell me they're cute
but of course they're gonna say he's
cute because yeah cause they don't want
him so i'm like be honest like i really
want to know yeah i want to know like
some ugly friends oh flaws i'll be like
we know if anyone's gonna point over
here
you're the one that immediately comes
into a kitchen is like this knife isn't
balanced um
and stuff like that and then she said
bring her of light and i was like oh boy
i can't i can't not say i cannot say it
like immediately that's that's way his
name that's his name well fill in the
blanks for people well if you watch the
zoom episode then you'll know why don't
yeah why don't you go watch all of our
episodes but um
the devil um well lucifer is called the
bringer of light and lucifer sounds like
luca now and i'm like i didn't think of
that before until she said bringer of
light and now that's all that's
and then i was trying to like save it
because i'm like whoa that just came out
of left field i didn't even know how to
like well i actually you went to the to
go get him and i was like you guys don't
want to tell do we say that
don't say it i was like what can i say
i'm not can't i can't see i'm trying not
to say it no and then i did i told you
to say it because then yeah but then i
was like no just say it like what
i'm too nosy to not know
but yeah then i tried saving and i was
like no he's my little angel and then i
mean
and then what happened later that night
oh yeah oh yeah i told jess i didn't
tell you what he's just speaking in
tongues projectile vomiting
and spinning what happened
no so like we put him to sleep like i
put him asleep at like in the completely
dark room it's just a tiny little night
light and he was i started glowing
he wasn't going to sleep yet and this is
normal you know he'll just be like
looking around staring but that
particular night i was like
are you looking at angels are you
looking at demons
[ __ ] now i'm just like because he always
smiles always always always always he's
smiling at the double he's smiling
looking at him he's always like staring
at him like hello father
oh my god i hate nicki minaj
yeah that show was funny you know before
you said bring her play i was thinking
the pixar movie i was thinking luca i
was thinking okay like kind of sounds
like lucas like star wars you know luke
i'm your father like like luke assault
that she loves to eat oh yeah yeah
and then you said bringer of light i was
like
that's literally what his name means the
morning star is uh
lucifer morning sphere of light is his
is his like slogan like the bringer of
light lucifer morningstar but that's the
bringer of truth right yeah that's what
that's why i illuminate illuminati god
and the devil are the same truth
when you told me his name is luca i had
a whole entire different dark reason why
i didn't
[Applause]
yes
[Applause]
i didn't pick it you know why it was a
traumatic birth to rosemary's baby
oh my god listen adulting can be hard
whether you're studying your butt off in
college starting a new job or just
getting parts of your life in order it
can often feel like a never-ending chore
favor makes taking care of your
reproductive health easy and painless
the pill club is now favor favor offers
professionally prescribed birth control
subscriptions and sexual wellness
products delivered straight to your door
for free favor carries over 120 fda
approved brands and ships to all 50
states most brands of birth control are
free with insurance or medicaid
otherwise prices start as low as seven
dollars per month without insurance
favor delivers birth control to your
door for free and discreet packaging
along with fun self-care gifts and
goodies and their licensed medical team
is just a text away to provide you the
care that you deserve sign up for birth
control in just five minutes skip the
office visit or waiting in line at the
pharmacy and get treated right right now
when you go to hayfavor.com big mood
fever is offering a 10 donation to
bedsider.org for every big mood listener
who becomes a patient your donation will
help low-income individuals get access
to birth control through bedsider.org
that's hayfavor.com big mood to get your
first birth control care package and
donate to help more women in need of
affordable birth control remember hey
favor.com big mood you must use the link
to make a donation mellower vibes are a
moment away with dead grass they'll take
you back to a time when music was on
vinyl books were bought in a store and
hipsters were a style of jeans and to
celebrate the passage of time they are
doing a special collab with george
harrison's estate to mark 50 years since
his all things must pass album dad grass
is legal organic smokeable hemp that
relaxes your body and mellows your mind
their 100 organic pre-rolled joints are
very low in thc and high in cbd so you
can enjoy the effects of cbd while
keeping a clear head chill out without
getting stoned it's like having a glass
of wine and not the whole bottle and
dadgrass knows you get by with a little
hemp from a friend they've partnered
with the george harrison estate to
create a new cbd and cbg blend and
accessories called all things musk grass
which pays tribute to the man who always
lets the good times roll all dad grass
products are federally legal for ages 21
and over and it ships right to your door
anywhere in the us whether you're
looking for a new buzz or a chill way to
enjoy an old favorite dad grass will
leave you in a euphoric mood right now
dad grass is offering our listeners 20
off your first order when you go to
dadgrass.com big mood go to dadgrass.com
big mood for 20 off your first order
again that's dadgrass.com
big mood what's his last name luca
magnata oh magnolia
you know what honestly any baby name
there's probably gonna be something
terrible probably worse than the devil
you haven't met him now you're not going
to touch all the apples he gives me no
wow that's cute you know what um you
know what's crazy though about luca's
name so we were going through a list of
names for boys
and when we hit luca i don't like it was
that same similar feel i don't know if
i've talked about this on camera but it
was that same similar feeling that i
talked about when i was a little girl
where i just had this gut intuition
feeling that one day i was gonna be
known by many people around the world
and i didn't know how or why and it
scared me i didn't know like it was just
like that's gonna be it that's the same
feeling
that's the same feeling i had when i we
first walked into our home or the model
home that we ended up buying i was like
and it was the very first house we saw
and i was like whoa i don't i really
like this house but i feel it in my
bones like this is your house
that's how i felt with the name luca we
didn't even know we were having yet but
i just felt like whoa like i i got that
tingly feeling again where i'm like
that's going to be his name but i don't
even i'm not even a fan it was really
i'm not really like super in love with
that name like i like it like it was
cute but like i wasn't like gone
what if you're gonna be known around the
world for giving birth to this child
specifically
oh my god right over the [ __ ] crack
in the house
he was conceived there you're right
no but yeah so i don't know i had that
feeling with luca even though there were
other names that i liked more
but i'm like
like seals above like
right
can we all just like just hit her just
one time i'm gonna be the favorite he's
going to love me the most i'm going to
make sure you're not like i know
i'll be like i know while you're here
and i will help you
oh my god
oh my god the next guy's going to be
named sam yeah
[Music]
whoever's on reddit should just write
this down for why big mood broke up
right
holy [ __ ] that'd be so funny it's
nikki's fault it's my fault it's your
fault
you're the mom okay
secondly definitely it would be luca's
fault right yeah no before baby
it's so weird
you know what he's not coming over
anymore guys
you ruined it nikki i blame you oh man
well i'm coming over you just have to
meet me i love me
i know gina we live in the same like
vicinity i know but then like you guys
were too scared to bring him out to
anyone right no actually you know what
it was waiting we were waiting for
casey's family to meet him first
so like he's only met my mom
and now casey's family
and now like now we're like okay cool
the parents or grandparents have met him
now let's open the floor they can open
the gates yeah that everyone's going to
come
here
oh god
wait wait why do people think that way
because my friend when my friend was
engaged she waited like a week and a
half to tell me because she was like i
was waiting so i could get a hold of my
grandma to tell my grandma i was like
[ __ ] why do you [ __ ] care that you
tell your grandma just tell me i'm your
friend i talk to you all the time you're
over here hiding this [ __ ] from me for a
week because you didn't tell your
grandma awesome people really care like
the elders care like my dad you're great
my dad came out
so like my dad knew that i was gonna
engage before i did and so he was
waiting for me for me to call him right
after i was drunk as [ __ ] first of all
and second of all um
i we didn't tell anybody we like i just
had we had the moment and i was like
really excited and i was crying and then
we just like went back to the hotel and
we we had like a long talk and it was
really romantic and then i was going to
tell the news like the next morning well
my dad was the first person i called and
he starts screaming at me that like you
didn't even call me didn't even tell me
he didn't even think i would like want
to know like i've been waiting i was
waiting by the phone all night i was
like
yeah like i guess like well that's a
little weird
you
the same night that's a little weird
yeah i was like you are the first person
yeah that's oh
my god but i'm like why why [ __ ] you
[ __ ] had conversations with me and
you knew if i could tell you because you
had to wait for your [ __ ] grandma
wherever the [ __ ] she is to find out
that you're engaged this whole time i
mean i get what you care but i don't get
why you don't get why she would want to
give yeah
he doesn't understand it doesn't make it
doesn't because it's not like i'm good
like you're gonna tell anyone or yeah
it's like her grandma would have
no clue
if i knew before her but then she knows
i think like your friend knows yeah it's
like the same yeah like i in my head
though like whoever the first person
that i talked to that week like they're
gonna find out like oh if you called me
like i'll [ __ ] tell you the same day
like if you just happen to call me like
i don't have to wait until i tell my
friends
whatever friends friends my whatever
monty and [ __ ] you know on the east
coast like i don't have to wait until
all those people know like if if we're
talking like i'm just going to tell you
it's weird i guess like her grandma's
really important to her i know but
that's what i don't understand like i'm
like i wasn't mad at her i was just like
like in a joking way like you don't get
like why did why did you [ __ ] have to
wait for
your grandma like a week and a half
later before you could tell me i'm like
i don't get it yeah it's weird maybe i'm
just a weird one but i don't think it's
like perfect that's what i'm like yeah
you don't have like because you don't
have like a big family with family
traditions right yeah like because i
would just like tell whoever came up
whoever popped up into my life i would
just tell them as life goes on but she
was like specifically waiting i was like
i don't get that the guy that makes her
starbucks drink
[Laughter]
can you understand why we would want
luca to meet his grandparents first
though no or that part is weird yeah
none of it makes sense to me i'm like if
i was in town and you had already passed
the point where the doctors tell you
like you know his immune system can
handle meeting people now and i was
already there you'd be like no you can't
come over until his grandma from dallas
flies in in the next like four months
and yeah why the [ __ ] why
well i don't think i don't have the
thing that has sentiment
um
yeah respect like it's like
i don't have a hierarchy
it's like it's like a
respecting your elders thing yeah we
don't have any of that in my family yeah
i would i understand that
yeah it's like it depends on how you
it's like you're giving someone else
privilege before them right like they're
special like yeah to be the first people
outside of us to meet him and like be
with him and also that's their first
grandchild like first blood grandchild
in their family yeah yeah to me it
doesn't matter in what order things
happen because like it like their
hierarchy exists regardless of the order
of things that happen so i just don't
understand how it works but it's not
that i'm offended or hurt by it i'm just
like wow you're just trying to
understand yeah
i just like when she said that she was
holding the secret for that whole time
and my head was just like that doesn't
make any sense to me like who gives a
[ __ ] you know what i mean like i don't
know it was one of those it wasn't like
i'm mad at you right yeah yeah i can't
stand people like that who are like the
people who dick who do get mad you know
like really really high maintenance
friends uh-huh
i'm glad you guys aren't that
well you were saying
yeah you missed it i actually want to
talk about this in another episode so we
can just talk about it yeah whatever we
want to talk about talk about it right
now well i'm saying like we're probably
towards the end of this episode right
now i guess i'll have to wait we are
going to continue having some like pow
wow such as i haven't even finished this
hand yet wow
thank you
outfit yeah yeah yeah like i have a
girlfriend who like you know like you
have multiple friends my friend has
another friend who's just like too high
maintenance just like okay well um let's
take pictures together no take another
one let's take another one now take
another one okay i'm gonna post first
and you guys post this i don't take
another one of me no take another one of
me well she's just not hanging out
yeah but how come we're not hanging out
yeah i know you have your boyfriend but
like why are we not hanging out like i
see like once a week oh my god i saw a
reddit post on am i the [ __ ] this
week saying
i was a maid of honor for my friend's
wedding am i the [ __ ] for saying that
i was unhappy that she's with him
and then wait she was a maid of honor
the maid of honor made a speech about
how
you know well she made a speech in the
speech holy watch wait no at the wedding
at the wedding
she was like i had a speech that i was i
wrote out that was very loving and sweet
but i feel like that's i'm lying to
everyone i want to be honest
ever since um whatever brittany since
you started with him like our friendship
hasn't been the same we used to see each
other once a week she says this in front
of her yeah
and she's like yeah yes you're the
[ __ ] yes and the whole reddit just i
would just destroyed her and she deleted
her account crazy she was insane and
she's deleted her account she deleted
her account but people do that all the
time
like fake accounts and delete them yeah
and like she's like we used to hang out
every week and then people were like do
you know that as an adult that's a lot
like a lot
already i don't i never asked for that
nikki once a week
we're gonna get into it in the next
episode yeah we will
oh you gotta strap in but yeah so like
the whole subreddit just absolutely
flamed her like you are [ __ ] insane
her friend wouldn't speak to her anymore
everyone's telling her she's selfish but
she didn't understand why she's like i
was just being honest you know like i
miss my friend it's like okay well
that's a private conversation yeah yeah
that's sweaty that's insane to me stupid
this which was crazy how do people not
understand that i don't understand
people who don't understand social media
i mean i was pretty chill as a bride i
didn't know all the rules in like
etiquettes and stuff and my
one of my maid of honors i had two
because well reasons um and the one of
them um
showed up with bright purple and blue
hair and i didn't know that that was
like a battery she wore a wig i know i'm
talking like that yeah um until my other
bridesmaids were like
do you just talk to her like you need to
grab the wedding
and i was like oh what's wrong with that
and they're like well because all the
pictures i was like oh i didn't even
think about that yeah pictures are
really expensive like photography is
like super could just edit her hair to
brown so that's a lot of work there's a
lot of work so we just put her on the
end of everything so that she could get
cropped out
of stuff i didn't because i didn't sound
like i have like i don't have my i put
the picture up right now
it's just like my memories are going to
be like how they were so you never
talked to her about it um they talked to
her about it and like why they changed
the arrangement of the order that we
were standing at the actual wedding but
um they're like you made a mistake so
you need to go to the end
you can't sit with us yeah
exactly um but i even that like like
that's too far like i have a line even
not having ever been to a wedding like
that is that was insane she gave a very
drunk speech squatting on the middle of
the dance floor oh my god
um jesus
but it was it was all about love and how
much she loves us yeah
and then she proceeds to take a [ __ ]
right yeah she's craps everywhere
but yeah that's the most interesting
pose i've seen on there for a while like
how does someone you're so socially
inept jesus
but anyways we're gonna end this um
episode because the next episode we
gotta fight yep um yeah
this time i fought with tiff and then
next toy i'm fighting with jess yeah
yeah so it's nikki's fault while we
break so this is
this is gonna be a four-week long fight
with every single person yeah this is a
documentary don't challenge us
thanks for watching you guys uh make
sure you guys follow us and click on all
the links below to all of our sponsors
um and we we will see you next week
[Music]
you